oh yeah dad I really like her what
should I do
well son you can do two things you can
just start kissing their however like me
I'm attracted the beautiful you know
it's like a magnet but don't move on her
like a little [ __ ] alright you just get
in there come on your star like this guy
you can do whatever you want they let
you do anything that's all that's all
what are you grabbing by the park
[Music]
excuse me never know how big is a
tremendous this is a tremendous and this
is a huge we got a loser
okay papers sir
I left my papers my jewel you're not
gonna get to your job unless you show me
your papers look I'm just trying to get
to work
do your papers belong at your job make
America great make America great you
trying to tell me if I look over my left
shoulder you won't hit me that's exactly
what I'm tied on believe you proved it
you never get to the face with a body
like that if you don't like it you can
always find another job did you hear
what he just said not true he said he
didn't say nope
are you serious okay two weeks ago
I'm speaking with myself number one
because I have a very good brain and
I've said a lot of things when I think
I'm right
nothing bothers me I could stand in the
middle of Fifth Avenue and shoot
somebody and I wouldn't lose voters you
have to treat him like [ __ ] you think
I'm gonna change you think I'm gonna
change I'm not changing I'm not changing
I'm just a [ __ ] businessman I'm just
a [ __ ] businessman I'm just a [ __ ]
businessman Jenkins this one looks like
trouble grab excuse me ma'am may we see
your papers please oh you know what
actually
it's crazy
this is why Jesus in the bed
poor walk yourself home